MINOR LEAGUE, MAJORLY OFFENSIVE.
>> MINOR LEAGUE BASEBALL
TEAMS OFTEN HAVE COOKY
PROMOTIONS TO DRIVE
ATTENDANCE LIKE THESE--THESE
ARE ALL REAL, BY THE WAY,
SPEED DATING NIGHT, GEORGE
CASTANZA NIGHT, LIPOSUCTION
GIVEAWAY NIGHT.
BUT THE ANGELS ROOKIE LEAGUE
AFFILIATE ORRIN OWLS WHICH
SOUNDS LIKE THE NEW DEFENSE
AGAINST THE DARK ARTS
TEACHER, RECENTLY FOUND
THEMSELVES IN A HOOT LOAD OF
TROUBLE WITH THEIR PROPOSED,
GOD I WISH I WAS KIDDING,
CAUCASIAN HERITAGE NIGHT.
OH, NO.
EVEN THE GHOST OF TY COBB
WAS LIKE, (BLEEP) THAT'S RACIST.
NOW THE OWLS, REACTING TO
BACKLASH, TURNED THEIR HEADS 180
DEGREES AND CANCELLED THE
PROMOTION.
SO COMEDIANS, I WOULD LIKE
YOU TO PITCH ME SOME OTHER
POORLY CONCEIVED MINOR
LEAGUE PROMOTIONS IN 60
SECONDS AND BEGIN.
>> SARA.
>> DUGGARS IN THE
DUGOUT NIGHT.
>>CHRIS: POINTS.
YOU COULDN'T FIT THEM ALL
IN THERE. RANDY.
>> UNREGISTERED SEX OFFENDER
NIGHT.
>>CHRIS: POINTS.
>> COME SHAKE HANDS WITH THE
ROCK'S NIECE NIGHT.
>> POINTS.
>> M NIGHT--YOU WERE DEAD
THE WHOLE TIME.
>> SO GOOD.
>> CHRIS: POINTS.
>> UNVACCINATED CHILD NIGHT.
>> NIGHT OF TOO MANY SCARS.
TOO MANY.
>>CHRIS: POINTS.
>> JAY.
>> ONE IN THE STINK NIGHT.
PART OF THEIR BACK DOOR
PROMOTION.
OPEN UP TO IT, AND
UNDERSTAND WHAT THEY DO.